the bitcoin and crypto haters they all
eventually capitulate they've had their
time in the sun they continue to say all
kinds of crazy things they continue to
say that bitcoin isn't valuable they
continue to talk about how
cryptocurrencies won't be sustainable
well ultimately what we have seen time
and time and time again is that the most
vocal critics end up learning more they
end up doing more work and they
ultimately end up becoming some of the
biggest bitcoin proponents here's the
latest example dhh david heinemeyer
hanson he's the co-founder and cto of
base camp he's the creator of ruby on
rails he's a best-selling author and he
has been an incredibly vocal bitcoin
critic he's had twitter war after
twitter war after twitter war with the
bitcoin community he's talked about how
it's not valuable how it uses too much
energy how he doesn't understand why it
will still last in the future but
recently the events in canada have
changed dhh's mind all of a sudden this
morning we saw a tweet come out where he
said i still can't believe that this is
the protest that would prove every
bitcoin crank a profit and for me to
have to slice a piece of humble pie and
admit that i was wrong on crypto's
fundamental necessity in western
democracies now before we take too much
of a victory lap let's see exactly what
dhh was talking about well in his piece
he says that he's been skeptical about
bitcoin and the rest of the crypto
universe and that in the early 2010s
some of his most ferocious twitter
battles have been with that community
and he still believes that there's a lot
to oppose he inaccurately says that
bitcoin's grotesque energy consumption
or that there's ridiculous transaction
fees or low throughput or obvious frauds
and stable coins etc but he does say
that his bigger beef was actually fueled
by a lack of imagination he could see
the fundamental promise of a digital
currency free of banks if you were
living in a failing state like venezuela
or an overtly authoritarian one like
china or iran but how is this relevant
to the vast number of bitcoin boosters
living in stable western democracies as
he goes deeper and deeper into the piece
what he starts to talk about is that his
eyes are opened by what the canadian
government has done he now believes that
the canadian government is also pursuing
an authoritarian strategy as well and so
now he recognizes why bitcoin as a
freedom technology is important both in
the developing and in the developed
world as well one thing that dhh made
that i thought was really interesting is
he said it actually took trudeau in
canada to do this because if it had been
trump in america a lot of people around
the world including those in europe
wouldn't have taken it as seriously they
simply would have written it off as just
one president in the united states for a
short period of time but everyone
believes that canada is a liberal
democracy they believe that justin
trudeau was actually somewhat of a
centrist but now we're seeing that if it
can happen in canada it can happen
anywhere and so i think we've got to
give kudos to dhh for recognizing the
true value proposition of bitcoin and
having the intellectual humility to
change his mind to talk about it
publicly but ultimately what he saw is
what millions and millions of people
around the world have seen as well is
that the canadian government is running
a marketing campaign for bitcoin bitcoin
is freedom technology it's censorship
resistance it prevents an authoritarian
government from overreaching from
encroaching on your personal liberties
bitcoin is inevitable bitcoin is good
for business and every single bitcoin
hater is eventually gonna figure out
that they need bitcoin as well so
whether you're a politician whether
you're just a talking head on twitter or
you're entrepreneur or an investor start
doing your homework because ultimately
you're going to need bitcoin